on murmure du ballet le sénat comme vous
ne l'avez jamais entendue
bienvenue dans l'écrin le mieux gardé du
jardin du luxembourg
[Musique]
autour de vous deux mille mètres carrés
de patrimoine vivant où évoluent des
plantes venues du monde entier
[Musique]
créé au xviie siècle par marie de
médicis le jardin du luxembourg s'est
enrichie au fil du temps de nouvelles
collections
le public peut ainsi admirer de
nombreuses variétés fruitières anciennes
et à la belle saison de superbes plantes
d'orangerie composant les grands par
terre
plus discrètes les serres du jardin
abrite quant à elle des collections de
plantes tropicales
administré et géré par le sénat depuis
1879 elles sont un lieu de production de
plantes utilisées pour l'embellissement
du jardin et la décoration florale du
palais du luxembourg
depuis le milieu du 19e siècle les
serres sont également un lieu de
conservation d'orchidées et de création
d'hybrides parmi toutes ces plantes
certaines peuvent vivre jusqu'à cent
cinquante ans
le premier groupe de serre présente un
climat humide elle abrite notamment des
cultures de fougères et de broméliacées
souvent utilisée comme plante verte dans
les décorations florales
le groupe suivant offre trois types de
climats et permet des cultures variées
plantes succulentes potées fleuries ou
encore plantes tropicales cette serre
permet la culture en photo période isme
les hortensias sont éclairées pour
fleurir hors saison tandis que les
poinsettias ses fleurs rouges en forme
des toiles sont mises au noir car elles
ne peuvent fleurir qu'un jour courent
toutes ces plantes sont alimentés en
solutions nutritives par un système de
goutte-à-goutte
à présent passons la porte de la plus
célèbre des serres du jardin du
luxembourg
elle abrite la fameuse collection
d'orchidées qui existe depuis 1839 et
répertorié d'intérêt national par le
conservatoire des collections végétales
spécialisées
on y compte treize mille potté est pas
moins de 1300 action elle est composée
de cette chapelle qui reproduisent les
différents climats des régions d'origine
des végétaux le coeur de cette
collection sont les patios pdil sommes
également appelé sabot de vénus ses
orchidées terrestre originaire d'asie
forme une rosette de feuilles allongées
une fois par an une tige en émerge et
porte une ou plusieurs fleurs à la
beauté singulière leur label prend en
effet la forme étrange d'un chausson ou
d'un sabot d'où leur surnom
dans cette serre moderne la gestion des
différents climats la température
l'hygrométrie l'aération et l'ombre âge
sont assurés par un ordinateur relié à
une station météorologique installés en
toiture
la nurserie est équipé d'un éclairage
photosynthétiques à led qui permet
d'allonger la durée du jour est de
compenser l'intensité lumineuse lorsque
celle ci est naturellement insuffisante
les jeunes plants d'orchidées né dans le
laboratoire de multiplication in vitro
de la conservation des jardins du sénat
peuvent ainsi s'acclimater et se
développer à leur rythme
[Musique]
à chaque arrosage les jardiniers
effectué un véritable contrôle sanitaire
par des traitements biologiques et
l'utilisation d'insectes auxiliaires il
aide les plantes à lutter contre les
maladies et les ravageurs tels que les
pucerons les chenilles ou encore les
champignons cette pratique s'appelle la
lutte intégrée
et c'est ainsi que la beauté et la
rareté de ce patrimoine vivant perdure
[Musique]